hey welcome to PlayStation grenade how
the hell are you I'm a person who loves
story in videogames and one of the
greatest things fortnight does to quench
this thirst is through gradual map
improvements and updates season 8 has
been the best by far with updates a few
times each week and only today what
looks like an alien spaceship has been
found under loot lake looks like heaven
the cube is responsible for something
again
but there are far more things happening
around the island there are five hidden
storage which can be found in the map
evolution during season 8 so if you're
ready let's do this as season 7 ended
tilted towers saw its building destroyed
yet again this time in an earthquake
which brought with it the volcano region
of the map that destruction smashed the
two stone characters hanging out around
wailing woods well did you notice that
they survived putting themselves back
together over the first few weeks until
the real love story began since that day
two star-crossed lovers have attempted
to get back to each other I'm going to
call them mr. and mrs. stone Steven
Sharon is RA they deserve to be together
we've seen Steve stone running back to
his lover we've seen Sharon Stone
different one playing it cool leading on
a tree Steve even picked up a flower for
his sweetheart what a guy taking out
kids bigs from women love plumps no idea
why the story took a horrible twist when
both were parted by a sea of fire Sharon
leaping straight into the flames certain
to perish
what a girl luckily though not only did
she survive she swam in molten lava and
got out the other side beckoning her
lover down to meet her like a real man
Steve jumped straight down no he didn't
no he didn't he's not that kind of guy
he's currently dropping down very
carefully to meet her I hope you kept
that flower what do you think will
happen when these two meet maybe a baby
Stone monster little baby brick or could
this mark the beginning of something
bigger could they become one giant
stones megazord like the power rangers
okay okay I'm going too far I'll back
away what do you reckon will happen with
the two stone people
the next story is the battle for food
supremacy over the last three seasons
the pizza pit crew and adder burger have
fought relentlessly both losing their
homes in the process they even took the
battle on the road using mobile kitchens
finally they both set up shop literally
across the street from each other in
retail Rome
right across the street from a taco
stand so this is the food capital of
board night then the tit-for-tat battle
began first Durr burger offered seating
for their customers before the pizza pit
crew went full throttle and erected a
new building der burger followed suit
and each week the buildings have been
growing this week though the inevitable
happened the der burgers mascot which we
haven't seen on top of the building
since season 3 reappeared coincidentally
the old G der burger still sits atop of
the hill near pleasant park but that one
has its original graffiti from when the
feature was first added but the ultimate
question is are you team der burger or
team pizza I hate them both equally to
mark the completion of both buildings in
retail the food fight game-mode has
returned with a deep fried element
quickly let's jump over to Viking
Valhalla
have you noticed what is happening down
it's not the shores the place where the
rich folk live and look out upon the sea
slowly been taken over by those battle
Vikings turning snobby shores into
Viking village this change has taken 8
weeks and still isn't complete yet there
are signs that the upper-class
homeowners attempted to fight back but
come on do you really stand a chance
against legit Vikings before we look at
the spaceship in live Lake let's
reminisce about the changes in tilted
towers since season 3 the destruction of
tilted towers has constantly threatened
first the rocket targeted it and then
moved on
but then the meteor annihilated a single
building over there after that a long
and hard rebuild began but it was done
but then Kevin the cube did it again and
took down the exact same building not to
be put off they erected a TV station
here this one must be staying right it
could link into the TVs around the world
and give us information inside it was
excellently put together it had studios
for broadcast vehicles and massive
structural weaknesses
honestly I was certain it was staying
but then season 8 happened and the exact
same building went down yet again not to
be put off the next building was created
this time an insurance company a cool
easter egg inside saw a diorama of all
the ways the building had been destroyed
previously I thought you I'd go have a
look for yourself
surely this building won't survive very
long after what was found under loot
lake
[Music]
okay let's tell the loot Lake story in
ultra quick time loot Lake was once a
lake with zero loot at all it was
terrible but all that changed when Kevin
the cube dissolved into it making it
like a trampoline then Kevin rose back
up and destroyed loot Lake making it
leaky Lake which had far more loot than
loot lake ever had so then it earned its
name back of loot Lake I've said loot
Lake a lot around Halloween Kevin took
his last breath and cried into the lake
and left us forever
fast-forward to season 8 and the volcano
lifting out at the island and pockets of
molten rock were found everywhere shown
by these geysers as the week's went on
the government became involved and began
a secret surveillance mission a
helicopter would move around the map but
what the hell was it looking for
suddenly workmen caming at seemingly
random areas of the map uncovering more
geysers a dusty divot though the
expected geyser went so low that instead
of air pockets we hit molten lava
instead and those workmen just simply
moved on they were looking for something
most definitely finally their search
ended by loot Lake the latest dig site
found a metal bunker
this made the faultline government go
into full search mode and ripped apart
loot Lake to discover what could be a
huge underground connected system or if
you've seen Independence Day you'll
recognize that ship's hull it's an alien
spaceship there's no promises that it
will take to the skies or be filled with
aliens it could simply be a hidden
bunker or could it be part of the Binda
tech story and save the world or maybe
just maybe it's an alien vessel to take
us to a brand new map or do you think if
it is an underground network you may
want to check around the houses in
retail row unpleasant Park brand-new
basements and hidden bunkers have been
found there so things are heating up or
do you think I'd love to know your
thoughts but thanks very much for
watching this video and an extra thank
you to the guys who supported me in the
fort night shop this week using code
Adam aru thank you very much you're also
my appreciate it massively without you
this video wouldn't exist right I'm
going to play my fortnight I'll see you
soon
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade
[Music]
[Applause]